the music world is mourning
grammy-nominated rapper Nipsey Hussle
who was killed in a shooting in los
angeles hustle was shot multiple times
yesterday in a parking lot outside his
clothing store two other men who were
also shot are in stable condition today
police are looking for the suspect
Hussle rose to stardom with self release
mixtapes who mid-2000s his debut album
victory lap was just nominated for Best
Rap Album at the Grammys in February the
artist also spoke and rapped about his
time with the notorious Crips gang as a
teenager the LAPD tweeted the rapper was
scheduled to meet with police leaders
today to discuss ways to stop gang
violence fellow artists are all paying
tribute to hustle on social media John
Legend said he just saw hustle on
Thursday tweeting he's utterly stunned
that he's gone too soon
hustle was 33 years old and the father
of two and everybody that knew him said
he was different than anybody they had
met Ava Duvernay calls him bright
genuine forward-thinking she'll remember
the beauty he's on his community LeBron
James Steph Curry and Rihanna says it
doesn't make any sense my spirit is
shaken by this this music was really
really life changing game changing he
was very well respected so this is a
inter loss to him